when we wrote the screenplay and
these characters really started
revealing themselves to us
my biggest fear was
who are the actors that we can get at
this micro budget level
that would make lucy become lucy
fully become lucy because lucy on the
surface could be a caricature jenny on
the surface could be a caricature any
one of the characters that you see on
there
can be caricatures and so when we went
out uh tamira sorvino who was someone
that i was praying would say yes to the
script
and when she responded yes i i knew like
half of my problems were over and then
my other half of my problems were solved
with tammy blanchard saying yes so that
was a big big moment for me the the the
accent is a bronx italian-american one
i've played two bronx italian-american
girls before one in uh sweet nothing by
kerry winnick and one in summer of sam
uh
spike lee's movie and so i'd had some
experience with it i had tape recorded
girls from the bronx and listened to
myself and back and forth and back and
forth but it had been a while maybe like
10 years so i used nancy as my new
template and uh i would ask her i say
how do you say dog how do you say god
how do you say you know because although
i am half italian american i'm not from
the bronx and i didn't grow up with a
sort of discernible accent um and the
voice the voice is sort of
i mean it comes with the personality you
know she has this very rangy personality
where she can be
extremely high strong and giddy and then
the voice kind of flies up but then she
comes down to earth she lands and she's
very insightful at moments you know
she's
she has moments of extreme lucidity
where she really tells it like it is and
kind of nails her sister on what the
truth really is and in those moments it
was a lot lower and more gravely and
everything but i don't know some of it
you know once i get into the character
it's not
managed and manipulated it's the
character speaking so
part of it was also my fantasy to
actually just make a to to do something
really micro budget and to own it and to
control it and and in this you know and
all the way through distribution um and
you know we're not alone i mean you know
spike lee just shot a film for a few
hundred thousand dollars uh john sales
starts shooting tuesday again a few
hundred thousand dollars uh alison
anders made a movie from kickstarter
jonathan demi just shot a film that
he shot all in one brownstone
and i think yeah i think this technology
is is really
i think helpful to you know when when i
can see this movie shot on a still
camera
and it looks like this in a theater like
this it's just it's it's amazing so i
think that that's the good news yeah was
one room with three walls of windows
and she wanted to shoot two cameras
so i was like okay um
yeah that was the challenge
and we were also we shot the whole movie
on the canon 5ds
which was great because they were small
and compact and we and we could move
around but
you know to keep the continuity of light
during that time and the way that nancy
and the actors worked
where they were more free so i didn't
want to put light stands and things all
over the place for them to
refrain that well yeah
anyway i mean we didn't have room well
we'd have to be like okay don't move
here you know um
but you know especially with mira's
character
she couldn't
go off anywhere
so we would just have to be ready to go
and
so yeah it was very strategic on
just you know boards and lights and and
basically time of day you know i just
nancy and i spent two weeks in there
you know
shot listing so it was
okay look at what time this this this so
we were very aware of making the
schedule with time of day to use the
natural light to our best and and then
little accents here and there in the
beginning you i thought people were
going to walk out of the theater because
it's such a such a disturbing hysterical
scene and you know all of us like jenny
probably want to run from this kind of
person in real life because it's too
much drama but then you know she turns
in a diamond she she can be really
lovable and and so much fun to play so
so instinctual and just full of life
there's a real sort of ball of life in
her which which uh i really enjoyed
having inhabit me um
and uh you know i was worried when when
i originally read the script i said
nancy she cries like six times or seven
times in the film and and maybe we
should you know be careful not to you
know exhaust the audience and so i think
a couple of the crying moments became
became less
they they the water works didn't happen
on those so that we would kind of pace
ourselves but um
so it was a big challenge to because we
were shooting these long takes you know
so they were masters really in a way and
so you couldn't stop and
now it's the close-ups of save it for
the close-up it all had to be there so
you were starting off laughing and
making some crazy joke and observing
things and all of a sudden an emotional
moment happens and you had to crumple
and and just have all that pain just
kind of come flowing out so that was the
that was the emotionally very taxing
side of playing this role but um but i
really do feel the role as a gift i love
this role